Speaker 1: Republican Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker's son has now brutally turned
on him and is denouncing Herschel Walker on the
same day that a woman has come forward and said
pro-life, Herschel Walker impregnated me, urged me
to get an abortion and then paid for the abortion.
We already talked about that. Here is Christian
Walker, a sort of known influencer. In fact, the I
guess he's called the legitimate son of Herschel
Walker. I don't really like that term because
you're not illegitimate just because your dad
doesn't want anything to do with you. But anyway,
he's called the legitimate son of Herschel Walker,
and he has had enough of Herschel Walker. He's had
enough of his own dad. Even though Herschel Walker
is a MAGA nut and Christian Walker is a MAGA nut.
Christian Walker tweeting yesterday, quote, Every
family member of Herschel Walker asked him not
to run for office because we all knew some of his
passed every single one. He decided to give us the
middle finger and air out all of his dirty laundry
in public while simultaneously lying about it
continuing. I know my mom and I would really
appreciate if my father, Herschel Walker,
stopped lying and making a mockery of us. You're
not a family man. When you left us to bang,
a bunch of women threatened to kill us and had
us move over six times in six months. Running
from your violence. I don't care about someone
who has a bad past and takes accountability,
but how dare you lie and act as though you're
some moral Christian upright man? You've lived
a life of destroying other people's lives.
How dare you? That's Hershel Walker's son.
And this is not about getting in the middle
of what is an obvious family problem. This is
about the disgusting dishonesty and hypocrisy of
Herschel Walker framing himself to the Republican
MAGA nuts of Georgia as the Christian guy, as
the moral guy, as the pro-life guy, whatever,
and being the complete and total opposite.
The only question that remains and I don't
have the answer to this, it's a it's a
question it's a predictive question we will
see in November is we know what happened
after the Trump Access Hollywood tape.
Nothing. He was elected president of the United
States. Are the Georgia Republican voters going
to look away again because they just really don't
like Democrats like Raphael Warnock? Or is this
going to doom Herschel Walker's campaign? Let
me know what you think. And all of these clips
we've played, we will have on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.